so the MCU might actually reset we've
been hearing about this from some
insiders but what exactly does this mean
what is the MCU
going to be like after Avengers secret
voice it's going to be completely
different it sounds like what's up
everybody welcome back I'm Warren and
with me today is La he was with me last
time he used to his beautiful face like
I said and we're going to be diving into
what well first of all secret Wars just
because it's so exciting but but what it
means to end Secret Wars and end the
Multiverse Saga and how the next Saga
comes into play like I said
insiders have been hinting like Secret
Wars is going to reset everything and we
don't know if it's going to be a hard
reset a soft reboot but that's what
we're here to talk about the
possibilities of what could happen right
away just your initial thoughts do you
think it should reset after
ah I mean from a personal standpoint
there's a part of me that would be a
little disappointed if we just like
completely started Anew but at the same
time just because you know I really care
about like what the MCU has laid down
which is this is why some of the
Multiverse stuff maybe feels a little
cheap is because it's like oh man don't
wash away all the hard work we did with
like the first phases right right but
then
we do need something to kind of shake it
up and make it more exciting introduce
new characters and it would expand like
the life the lifeline or like the
lifespan of the MCU sure um whether or
not that's a good thing which means to
be seen but that's the question isn't it
but I I mean I can definitely see it
being a major possibility though it
makes sense that if they if they went
that route how about you well here
a follow-up question before I answer
okay how do you feel about if it's a if
it's like a full reboot right like it's
like we're wiping this like clean it's
like DC right like we're wiping this
light clean here it is and they're like
all right full reboot now we can have a
new Iron Man
Captain America Thor like how does that
make you feel right away
ah it's it's hard because like you know
you you casted some pretty iconic or
like rather the characters became iconic
with because of it right exactly yes yes
and and to try to match that would be
really hard uh I also would be kind of
like annoyed if like we finally get
X-Men and it has nothing to do with the
MCU as I loved it and that's true too
you know what I mean yeah yeah good
point so so it would feel kind of cheap
I would understand it from a business
standpoint but I don't think I would
like it very much but then again I don't
know maybe it could be very clever how
it's handled but like right I don't
really want another Iron Man if it's not
Robert Downey Jr I know that and I think
that's how a lot of people feel right
now but you did say you know if they
find a clever way to do it and I think
there are like advantages and
disadvantages to doing it
but I I think it actually starts with
how they're going to approach Secret
Wars because one thing that we've heard
recently is is Secret Wars is kind of
going to be
this is gonna sound kind of weird but
the finale to
all the Marvel stuff we've seen even
prior to the MCU beginning with Iron Man
so let's take it back to X-Men which was
sure basically the first one if we're
not counting like the older movies like
Fantastic Four like the way
right exactly yeah yeah not with like
Jessica Alba but the one yeah right so
if we're gonna take it back I believe it
starts the uh the X-Men and then
Spider-Man
so Secret Wars is kind of a farewell to
this whole
superhero under Marvel of course era
right so and we've heard that we've
heard Kevin feige is kind of making
secret Wars it sounds like Deadpool
three
um like a farewell like uh like hey
because he started with he was with
Marvel uh when X-Men started right he he
was an assistant producer and then just
boom and moved up until you know he was
now he's the president right so
all of these people that I worked with
before all these projects it's kind of
cool like really Secret Wars is yeah is
everything coming together from such a
very long time it's it's poetic almost
right I mean it's it's romantic right
and so
that's why it's been like oh this is
kind of like him saying goodbye
and when he says goodbye it's kind of
like ending
a whole era including the infinity Saga
and possibly now the multiversary of the
MCU so if it if it ends that way on a
very good poetic awesome note and you
see Wolverine and Deadpool and Toby
Maguire and James Marsden is cyclop you
know like like and you're seeing all of
this stuff right I mean that's gonna be
just so cool
right and everybody everybody thinks
like oh this is what we hope happens
right because
I think a lot of people including myself
thought Multiverse Madness was going to
be like Cameo Cameo Cameo but I truly
think Secret Wars is gonna be like that
so I think if they hit us with all that
the it's it could be so big that a
reboot
might feel
fresh nice yeah yeah yeah I was gonna
say I was gonna say refreshing yes
exactly it might actually feel because
you get like oh oh like boom yeah and
it's almost like you need some time to
come down from it right and you're sure
okay well let's just well they could be
like well we're giving you time we're
gonna start no yeah and I might be like
I'm down you know what I mean I I do
feel like I'm like oh no don't recast
Iron Man
but they don't have to right away they
could do it don't jump and that's the
smartest way to do it is to not try to
redo all those things like you know like
yeah don't don't make it the same
alternatively what if they go into the
path of like this might be a little out
of the box but like you have like Matt
Reeves Batman right but you also had
like the well like you also had you know
like whatever else is coming yeah do do
we you is it gonna be a time where it's
like more experimental takes on the
characters like I don't know like would
that be interesting probably probably
would make sense to keep it franchising
right but right yeah but that's the
whole thing yeah right and I definitely
wouldn't start with like Captain America
no more iron again right like yeah you
got to find your other pockets and it
might be the New Mutants you know that
might be our intro who knows regardless
I think that's the direction they go
so basically we just talked about a hard
reboot there is a possibility of soft
reboot right so
you know for example like maybe the
Scarlet Witch you know classic House of
them no more mutants something else like
no more Multiverse and and and it kind
of starts over but like remnants are
left of it so like so like maybe like a
bunch of multiverses com universes
combined from the Multiverse into one
Universe yeah and it's like well now you
have the mutants and everything that
happened before in the MCU but now you
can just just focus on the mutant story
moving forward the Fantastic Four story
moving forward have callbacks to The
Avengers every now and then right and
then they come together 10 years later
whatever it may be sure right so that's
like the soft rebit option isn't bad
there's several ways to do that one is
like the universe could start again
but maybe from uh
maybe they all get a new universe and
they have to rebuild it yeah so people
remember things that happened in the
past right but it still is new or maybe
you know at the end it they a lot of
different things do get fused together I
guess I'm saying the same thing well
it's so funny that you're bringing it up
because this is like this is a storyline
and spoiler alert Mortal Kombat the
video game Mortal Kombat one is that Lou
King had to re-establish a brand new
timeline and then he placed characters
that he wanted in different life
circumstances and then built a new
universe that was pure kind of like Kang
did or sorry
um he who remains did right right and so
that's kind of an interesting concept to
me where it's like yeah we still have a
Captain America we still have this but
we also have like oh this guy has been
here for a while even though it's like a
new character so it's like that's that's
also an option and the idea of like a
keeper of time or like a Godly like
deity yeah I I mean that fits within the
MCU as we stand I mean we saw we've been
seeing God show up oh in the MCU you
know the end we have eternity yeah we
had a tournament that's like the biggest
one we've seen we know Valhalla exists
you know like so the so the the concept
of something big like bigger right
controlling would totally make sense and
we have seen the Living Tribunal yes
absolutely yes so uh you just you just
said something that sparked an idea that
I had like a week ago was What if
because I always think about like what's
gonna happen after like are they gonna
reboot they gonna keep going
um because in the in the comics like
they they essentially do restore the
Multiverse to an extent and of course
that's an option like they just restore
it and they move forward and then
they're aware that there's a Multiverse
and then maybe moving forward you can
Universe jump yeah right because there's
a council of reads Reed Richards Mr
Fantastic they all communicate with each
other I would love a multiversal
illuminati like the one like you choose
one person from each Universe to be
responsible for like you know what I
mean but I thought so maybe in some type
of a reboot
maybe you get just like maybe the heroes
decide like well we can't
we can't really restore what we had but
maybe they in like outside of a
space-time thing like the TVA maybe like
all the remaining Avengers like doctor
strange and the Scarlet Witch or whoever
maybe they kind of become the TVA maybe
they become responsible for creating a
new universe Multiverse whatever it may
be that way it's kind of like you can
start off with a new universe and then
you can maybe in the future like
be like you know how this you know how
like the legend of how this universe was
like created right like there were
Heroes like us before
and they stopped this conqueror who had
thousands of variants and then they
rebuilt it and they watch over us now
right it's it's yeah the kind of like
the like a God would do right you don't
really create a universe and I I don't
think that'll happen at all right
um it's a pretty big concept for like a
commercial audience right yeah consume
yeah but I like the idea of that like a
multiversal illuminati or right exactly
team like that's what I was that's what
I thought we were going to get in Doctor
Strange you know right but and so so now
maybe we get that in in full I don't
know it's it's def like you said there's
so many paths they can take to either
soft hard or no reboot at all right like
we it could just be Kevin feige Swan
Song and then someone else comes in and
re-establishes oh a new a new era you
know don't say that because that's very
that's a very real thing Kevin feige
could say you know what this wasn't just
like my farewell to like the X-Men and
stuff
farewell yeah yeah oh no we'll talk
about this in detail in just a bit but
first big thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you may
know that I personally use hellofresh
and I love it it makes cooking fun easy
and it's affordable and that's why it's
America's number one meal kit delivered
straight to your door and you might not
know that they actually have seasonal
recipes right now since it's summer they
have their new fresh and fit summer menu
so if you're trying to get that beach
bud but you're also trying to eat really
great tasting food it's perfect for you
right now it's peak time for summer
produce and hellofresh make sure you get
all the best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now if you go to hellofresh.com
50 Cosmic you can use code of 50 Cosmic
for 50 off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic to pour 50 off your order and
free shipping and uh you know what's sad
is like I think a lot of people now
would welcome might welcome that I don't
think the MC has been really as bad as
people make it out to be I think there's
a few loud people and Everyone's
entitled to their own opinion right if
you don't like it that's you know it's
just not all of them are winners anymore
and he like in my they were in the past
though like not everything like Thor
dark World Iron Man 3 but it's still
enjoyable and still like interesting to
me to just to hold my attention I think
the problem just going back to what you
just said it's not the fact that they're
not all winners because we you know not
all we're winners in the past but mixed
in with that were some bangers and I
feel like there's been a Miss of bangers
recently right because I feel it feels
like oh this one was okay but then this
one and then this one were awesome and
then these other two were okay but then
this one was awesome then I feel like
people would be like oh that's okay but
I feel like a lot of people think a lot
of them have missed lately
um but for me like
nothing's been so except for like the
ending of secret Invasion
besides that nothing's and like I even
enjoyed that fight it was like cool but
writing wise was just terrible but
anyways um besides that I haven't like
truly hated anything and been like oh
this is garbage I lied what people know
that
it's not that I guess it's not that I
hated what if but I like when you have
some like MCU and it doesn't really
serve a purpose I'm just kind of like
why am I
but anyways uh it
yeah I mean I wouldn't in that sense
would the reboot would a reboot and
would a new Marvel President coming in
be better or would it be better to keep
Kevin feige and continue on with the
story with a broken Multiverse or like
an infused Multiverse where it's like a
bunch of universes aren't one and that's
how you get the mutants right because
maybe they don't exist in our universe
they exist another one then they come
over to ours and it's like hey here you
go you have the mutants because at the
same time I think I would like
I think I would like kind of like a
build up for the mutants like they did
with the Avengers you introduce one and
one and one and then oh hey here here's
Professor Xavier he starts to recruit
them all and now we have X-Men yeah
right that would be awesome yeah I think
I would enjoy that more than like hey by
the way here the X-Men are in your
Universe now but we're at a place in the
MCU where so much has happened that
people will start asking questions of
like where were they during Thanos and
that's so hard because it's like yeah
you want Fantastic Four to show up in
the MCU but you're gonna be expecting
him at full full functioning right
Fantastic Four you're gonna expect the
mutants to be full functioning X-Men I
would love to see those Origins happen
and that only can take place in like
flashback or era style movies right now
um what should I do or Multiverse right
but the thing is and I think this is
just maybe it's a hot take but I feel
like audiences for the sake of the
audience rather we need to get the hell
away from Multiverse ASAP you think wrap
it up yeah because you think it's like a
cop-out
I think it's too big of a concept to
keep stretching right okay King is
supposed to be this big threat right
right if they don't show us how big that
threat is and soon or like how that all
ties in it's just I think it is maybe
maybe I do think it's a cop-out but I
think it's
it it lessens the stakes overall for me
because it's so big you know what I mean
it makes makes sense right like I I
think at the end of King Dynasty we're
gonna lose yeah and then they're gonna
go well let's just go to another
universe and get some help and see what
they've done and like
you know and I think you can write that
in a really great way I'm really looking
forward to that actually but yeah it
gets kind of weird
because there's like a report that
the Fantastic Four film might actually
take place in Another Universe
and then in like Secret Wars they get
brought into ours and then I'm like okay
so then
they stay after yeah you know what I
mean like that's the only way to fix
everything is that opens up really big
questions yeah yeah yeah it's just like
so okay either they stay in our universe
after
because theirs is destroyed and oh now
we're in a new universe
but like you said at that point they're
gonna be established already yeah of
course it's gonna be like oh I have to
adjust to this new world because it's
also said that
it's going to take place in the 1960s
that's been Rumor for years now
but I believe Grace rant yeah Grace
Randolph is the person who reported
1960s and other universe and I've
thought of this before because I was
like if if you're gonna show us like
a threat of King the Conqueror to the
entire Multiverse not just one Universe
you might want to show us the
perspective of other universes as well
to like to your point to show us how bad
he actually is yeah show the threat
because let's be honest it did not come
across in Quantum Mania no because ants
killed or defeated him and I was so
pissed about that because I'm just like
you literally have the power to stop
time you've we saw you in the movie stop
like people in time just do that like I
one thing that I it doesn't bug me so
much but every it bugs me when it's an
easy way to like defeat a villain is the
giant CGI Army thing yeah that's the
time I don't care
because it's not the giant cji army
defeating the characters but in this
case it was the giant CGI Army and
you're like
controlling them it's like no it was
ants like it was these little ants and
then you know then Ant-Man after and
then they had like a fist fight but
really what happened was it was the ants
that came down and yeah destroyed his
suit
you literally just showed us him
evaporating people out of his existence
he could have easily done that
I just to me that's where I I'm like oh
that was kind of I was like this was
your big bad show-off and he lost to
ants like that's why I was so mad
especially because the previews look
really good when he's yelling like I am
kind and I'm like all right all right
all right you'd like compare that to
when Thanos like turns into chair and
Guardians and he's like I will bathe the
star ways in that blood right yeah
versus that myself yeah yeah like these
like really bone-chilling intros well
and I guess you could say
that was probably what the post-credit
was supposed to be the the the trio of
Kings the Council of Kings right yeah
like oh this guy he was pretty rough but
actually like there's there's way more
stronger and there's also a lot of them
yeah and I like the idea of thousands of
them but I also like the idea that there
are like three above everybody because
then it's like you know it's like oh
yeah it's a big threat but you need
something to hone in to govern right
yeah and I I really like what you said
it's just like show us those Mo like we
want Multiverse stuff in in the in the
same way that like spider versus kind of
happening right it's just like sweeping
like you see multiple Universe you
actually live there for a little bit
right right yeah yeah that's all that's
all that's right five seconds like they
did what has he done you know don't just
show me like your little desktop
hologram description of what right right
you know Nathaniel Richards has done
over time show me and show me this
Stakes because
damn it's uh I feel like we're playing
catch-up right now in terms of like
giving him backs not backstory but like
no I feel you Threat Level right level
yeah yeah so we'll see what Dynasty
brings but there's uh you know there's
only a few handful of uh projects in
between yeah to make that happen to show
us yeah yeah and then and then I really
like want them to lose again in secret
Wars yeah and I really want it to be
like at the end it's like they defeat
Kang but it's like we have no way
to fix the Multiverse like it's it's
destroyed and something happens and
maybe Cosmic entities come into place
maybe the Scarlet Witch does something
or maybe they're like we just have to
all live together now yeah right and
that's the new MCU that's the new MCU
and I think that would be
intriguing it would be right yeah you'd
be like oh wow but again
and it's it's weird because I do want
and it could well actually now I'm
thinking about it now because clearly
our main timeline our main Universe the
MCU Earth 616 we're starting to get
people who have mutations right Kamala
Khan they said that you know she's a
mutant straight up yeah no more
kind of said he said he was a mutant but
yeah I always think in that frame he
wasn't referring to like the mutants of
the X-Men right I think he was just
saying like I have a mutation right so
but it is it's still very apparent that
Marvel Studios is planning something so
maybe it's kind of like the there are
some X-Men left over and then people are
all of a sudden are like well wonder if
we had those in our universe and then
all of a sudden kamala's like well
actually they found something in my DNA
and then all of a sudden the New Mutants
who are truly new and fresh yeah because
they've never you know then they come
and then they have mentors from other
X-Men that could be an option and it
would make the Discrimination storyline
of the X-Men really stand out because
not only are these Outsiders in terms of
ability but we've had super power people
it makes them strange is that they're
not from our existence or like reality
all right that's a good that's a good
point yeah and then it becomes less
about because you know it was always
about race or like you know The
Outsiders of the time you know uh lgbtq
at the time right all these different
people
but then if it's like you know it almost
like
how do I say this it generalizes the
Discrimination to like something a
little bit more nebulous and easier to
understand you know what I mean yeah
like who are these people it could just
like we could talk about the mutants
obviously but really it would be
it'd be kind of like what they brought
up in secret Invasion like who's gonna
be okay with the Scrolls living on this
planet exactly but like actually maybe
we actually talk about it this time yeah
right yeah well I mean maybe
Captain America Brave New World yeah and
that's that's the other thing we still
have the Marvels we still have Captain
America Daredevils in between there now
right there's a lot there's there's a
lot to keep us like still like
in a direction as as far as right now
we're theorizing obviously as always
like we don't know it's what we do but
but in terms of like a reboot yeah I
could see I could really see it going
any of those ways there's a lot of
options there are a lot of options and
I'm curious to hear what everybody
thinks about this
so reboot hard reboot hard soft reboot
meaning like you start from the
beginning but some remnants are left
over
I don't I'm not entirely sure what how
that situation would arise yeah you
could have something to do with maybe
the Scarlet Witch saying no more
something I like that idea because I
always thought she was gonna say instead
of no more mutants no more humans or
like more mutants just like bringing
them in well right because that would be
our house event yeah I thought that
would be really cool like in one
division or or yeah or Multiverse of
Madness if you just wanted more people
like her
yeah she was just like
more more superhumans you know more
enhanced individuals or something like
that and you know and you could easily
walk into the the name mutant they
already are they already did with Miss
Marvel yeah yeah they have it now right
so the concept can be established and
then yeah because
I think it's gonna be some type of
combination of like doctor strange and
the Scarlet Witch and Reed Richards like
using actual technology yeah with like
Bruce Banner and stuff at the end kind
of showing like this is the only way we
can move forward and it's like we're
either gonna reset
and
I mean you know they're
I guess like the whole thing King is the
master of time travel they could
probably get their hands in some gear
and maybe yeah time travel but maybe
it's kind of like the thing where it's
like well some things are messed up now
yeah you know what I'm saying right yeah
now some people are mutated maybe
because it's kind of like I don't know
time travel gets tricky so it's
maybe maybe you can't completely erase
everything but you can
restore the Multiverse some way I was
going to say time travel does get tricky
but multiversal travel is even weirdly
convenient actually right you could just
pull from oh this universe has you know
yeah and that that's like the the
Erasure of stakes but you know it could
be soft boiled hard-boiled scrambled
boiled Multiverse who knows what's gonna
happen I don't know but I yeah so I'm
curious if like we if we do a hard
reboot and we and we get a new Captain
America Iron Man all that stuff like I'm
curious to hear what everybody thinks of
that if you like that idea if you don't
like that idea because it's hard it's
hard to to
like if I say Iron Man Robert Downey
Junior probably
who do they voice match in animated
shows you know what I mean it's right
yeah and even
um
like Sam Wilson is the new Captain
America but I still in my videos have to
say sam Wilson's Captain America because
if you say Captain America the first
thing that comes to your mind is Chris
Evans yeah yeah so I'm
I'm happy that we don't really know
truly what's gonna happen
I am happy not knowing what's gonna
happen
am I concerned about the future yes but
in like a good way yeah it's because
it's because Uncharted Uncharted
territories and you're just you don't
know how you'll feel about whatever
decision they make but I am excited
because I think
well what I hope Kim feige steaks and
two I think I I think they'll
they'll they'll they'll put the time
effort and Care into deciding where to
go in the future yeah but but going back
to what we said in the beginning I do
think the X-Men are the future I think
we move away a little bit from The
Avengers and it's more X-Men and
Fantastic Four I feel like all those Fox
properties from back in the early 2000s
are gonna get their due in their
Resurgence now you know like I totally
agree with that it's I think that's our
future it's less Avengers and it's more
X-Men Fantastic Four I mean I I'll be
honest one of my dream projects would be
X-Men versus Avengers I don't know how
we would get there well no I I actually
don't think it would be that hard to do
that well okay let me rephrase
considering what they do with the
Multiverse and the reboots and
everything right exactly I don't think
it would be because it's not too hard to
to show a universe where you know it was
kind of the mutants verse everybody it
was a mutant versus the humans because
they you know they feared them and the
Avengers maybe fear them as well right
because yeah they didn't play night
because they're a good X-Men and bad
X-Men right so it's like you know I
think it gets I think there are a lot of
ways to to do that actually especially
when it comes to people who like Iron
Man maybe have Tech
powered
you know and and people who are born
with it and then it it in my mind it's
almost like Civil War right there are
people there are people who are just
responsible and want to fit into society
and be helpful and there are people like
Magneto who are like no we are the
dominant race yeah like I mean you
kidding me I can move crap in my mind I
can move metal you know yeah teleport we
are superior you will listen to us yeah
there's lots of ways to do that which
I'm really excited about or they could
just go to the comic route where they're
like kind of friends and then you know
stuff happens and they're playing
against stuff happens yeah this thing
you know you have a name well we already
saw that in a more
you know flooding wakanda then you have
a black panther and storm getting a
divorce and you know there's a lot of
ways you can do that and yeah I'm with
you on that one I'd be really excited
for that and that that's the thing is
like there are so there's so much you
can do in the future of MCU that's why
I'm so excited about it I just don't
know how they're gonna
I mean MCU when it started was the first
of its kind you know what I mean like
yeah we've had superhero content before
but not the way this is strung along and
the fact that it's at 20 like reaching
20 years soon like like in no time 2008
right yeah that's like five years yeah
we're we're climbing towards you so it
would make sense to find some kind of
resolution for that but because like I
don't know I I think about new viewers
right yeah and this will probably be my
last thought on the on it but like
I think about new viewers and you tell
them that you love Marvel and if they
don't know what's if they've been living
under a rock or haven't seen like their
earlier films there's a lot to catch up
on yeah so a reboot would allow an A A
pathway for new viewers just jump in
right a brand new starting point and I
think for a lot of people they were like
oh that's what and after end game would
be no we were still very much connected
to all of the rest you know yeah and
that's I mean it was such a satisfying
moment Infinity war and end game okay
and like even to a point the Multiverse
Saga there's a lot of payoff that's like
cool I'm glad that we're here you know
yeah because like now we get cameos of
like John Krasinski is Reed Richards
which I you know I thought was funny
because it was like an internet thing
you know right right yeah yeah but for
new viewers I can tell I can see the
benefit of that because then it's not
it's daunting to just like enter enter
are in from like that
yeah that's a really good point not only
to just like new viewers but like the
Casual viewers yeah
you gotta imagine like people who are
like casual fans of DC that don't go on
YouTube and the internet every day are
kind of like what the crap is going on
this is bug boy what is happening
Batman's connected it's not connected
there's this one Batman movie that's
kind of set back in time but like it's
what is happening we have this Joker
movie then we have this Suicide Squad
like it like honestly that's a really
good point you bring up it could bring a
lot of
Simplicity to things actually Simplicity
yeah yeah a chance for it
that's a good that's a really good
argument actually and I don't think
what's interesting is I don't think it's
too complicated right now but once you
dive further into the Multiverse I think
it actually does get pretty complicated
yeah for for like normal casual people
not like to nerds I guess yeah Anna we
eat that up right yeah just seeing how
people reacted to the cosmic stuff and
the eternals I was like oh this nerdy
nerdy deep comic stuff is not for
everyone you know what I mean no they
don't fully like get the like feel the
grasp of it like right they don't buy
into those Stakes as much yeah right
like an end game I was kind of
disappointed I really don't have
anything against Captain Marvel and I
I'm really looking forward to the
Marvels and let me specify that the
character Captain Marvel and Brie Larson
I Marvel's was or Captain Marvel one was
like yeah it was fine it was fine right
I don't hate it I don't hate Brie Larson
or the character Captain Marvel looking
forward to the Marvels but in end game
when they started shooting the sky I'm
like the lemon tribunal showing up and
then it was Captain Marvel's like never
mind
[Laughter]
the living tributors interfering
timeline and like that's a No-No and
like all this stuff because you you like
uh like mordo has the staff of the
living tribute and all that stuff like
there's I've been cool yeah I'm like
dude that would have been and it's funny
because I actually saw a few people's
like tweet after they were like I really
wish this Theory came true man I'm like
yeah me too because like I was like it
would make sense for him to
kind of step in and be like all right yo
hold up my job to uh judge so but yeah
but go ahead and let us know what you
think about all of that law you made a
really good point there at the end about
that so maybe the reboot is the way to
go but what do y'all think a reboot soft
reboot or just fuse at all hey we can't
fix the Multiverse
we're all going forward in one universe
or maybe just like a few from now on and
like yeah maybe the TVA will monitor it
so we don't have this big old battle
again what's the best option in your
opinion let us know in the comments down
below don't forget to follow law we'll
link all of his stuff he'll be back
again so be sure to show him some love
and uh don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and we'll catch you all in the
next podcast
woof